let's go to memphis tennessee
where brian joins us brian how can we
help
uh harry i just uh me and wife have just
started this
and uh about two weeks ago
and uh we we hear a lot about combining
our
money we've always had separate money
and i
picked up on that from some older
couples that i had met that
seemed to get along better than most
couples and they all had separate money
so i've pushed that from the beginning
and uh
just wondering how we would benefit by
enjoying our money together
help me understand why why you do not
want to uh brian
um i hear what you're saying about the
other people but what's your reason to
why
you believe you shouldn't combine it i
just kind of saw the
older couples you know that seemed to
have seemed to get along better than
most
so i mean like y'all said before most
arguments are over
money so us having separate money that's
not really an issue and we're neither
one of us are greedy you know like we're
both willing to help each other if
something come up financially like she
has more debt than me
and i have no problem once we once we're
building the debt snowball when i pay my
debt off i'm jumping on her debt
oh hold on here here's here's okay all
right ao you take it yeah
i mean well no you're married you gotta
speak into this i'm not ready to
because i i i'm not i'm not married so i
can't speak into
uh certain things of the marriage aspect
but one thing i do know
okay brian uh and be real with you
brother cause i love you
um there is no my debt her debt there is
no my money his money there is no
when you two say i do and
when two become one everything becomes
that
one now do i believe that you two
and ken i'm pretty sure when you and
your wife got married there had to be a
very serious conversation to all right
this is how we're going to combine
everything that makes sense so we will
not have any issues um going forth in a
marriage but i
i from what i know brian uh when i get
married to my wife
her dad becomes my dad if i have if she
has any debt
um her money becomes my money my money
becomes her money and we're going to
work on this thing together
yeah brian listen here's the deal i i
want to poke some holes in what seems to
be a solid theory to you
because i think you really believe that
you saw
happy older couples who had this
particular philosophy
about separate bank accounts and you
said well it worked for them it'll work
for us and
and i think you really believe that it's
worked for you so far but
anthony nailed it uh the big issue is is
that it's not her debt
and then your debt and it's not you well
i'm going to pay mine off and then i'm
going to throw all my money at hers
because there will always be with
separate accounts there will be separate
goals
there will be separate emotions and
there will be separate actions
all related to money you cannot
separate accounts and then have unified
actions
and that's why we recommend what we
recommend it is just
counter-intuitive even though it makes
sense to you
it's counterintuitive to a unified
marriage and a strong marriage
and so i would really challenge you to
really think this through and here's
where i'm going to poke the hole in your
theory
you don't have any evidence that i'm
aware of you haven't shared it
of these couples where you sat down with
these men
and these couples you said couples
plural and you sat down with these men
and said hey
frank pete
tell me about all the good things in
your marriage because you guys had
separate bank accounts
that that evidence doesn't exist and
while you saw some couples in whatever
limited experience you had with them
not throwing a frying pan at each other
not cussing each other out
uh not not being negative and cheating
on each other and all these you saw that
you went well it kind of looks
they look kind of normal to me it sounds
like a good idea and i'm going to
challenge you you don't have any
evidence
that says that that's the best thing for
the marriage the second thing i'm going
to challenge you on
is that this thing is really about you
this isn't about an example that you saw
with another couple or two this is
you kind of like having your sandbox and
i and i'm assuming your wife likes
having her sandbox
and that's a real problem because i
don't even know if kids are in the
picture i didn't want to bring that up
because that's
really gnarly so no don't do that we
know you're new to the show i'm so
excited that you're listening to the
dave ramsey show and that you're diving
on the baby steps
but this needs to be a wee thing
not a you and her thing and we try to
even
individually get to the same place it's
just never going to pan out well and at
the end of the day two is better than
one
okay and so when you all have
uh joint accounts you have a joint
mission you have a
joint assignment you all are going down
this road together
you're going to get there quicker
because you all are together
on the same page and you all are helping
each other keep that momentum up that's
one thing
i'm looking forward to when i'm getting
married because now
i'm stronger because i have a partner
with me and together
we're going somewhere it's not i'm going
over here bae um i'll talk to you when
you get over there and i'm i'm gonna go
be debt free
and i'm gonna do the debt free scream uh
with ken coleman and anthony o'neil the
show but you're going to be on the
sidelines because you're not debt free
yet it's a very good point and that's
exactly
the cash in there kelly let's give brian
and his wife
a free subscription to ramsey plus which
is our
brand new subscription based program
that is just
unbelievable it has all three of the
tools that you all need to get on the
same page and win
one is financial peace university all
nine weeks of the course
the second is our unbelievably
unparalleled
world-class budgeting app every dollar
connects right to your bank account
where every dollar is where it's going
how it got there
why it left and then your gold tracking
app the baby steps gold tracker app
all of that plus more in ramsey plus so
brian that is my gift to you
yeah and uh and from anthony let's just
call that a uh
a late wedding present but you all
need to get on the same page